did you know that storytelling can make
your copyrighting up to 22 times more
memorable than facts alone which is
exactly why in today's video I'm going
to give you seven storytelling tips to
help you drill your copy into your
reader brains but before we dive into
the video if you are a copywriter which
I presume you are then I have a gift for
you in the link in the description below
I have copyrighting Catalyst which is my
63 cash cow copyrighting tips that you
can get for free it's a free
copyrighting guide literally click the
link put your email in and you will get
an email from me with this free micro
course that you can start learning from
today so enjoy that if you're a
copywriter let's dive into the video
storytelling tip number one is use
dialogue or show don't tell most
copywriters will start stories like I
was walking in a Cafe to meet a friend
and we sat down and started having a
conversation when in reality something
more Dynamic is to make the scene come
alive actually tell what happened you
walk in you say hey John great to see
you my friend Hey Joe my man you look
fantastic how did you lose all this
weight you see that dialogue that back
and forth starts a conversation and that
rabbit hole actually sucks the reader in
very much like fiction novels they use
this very heavily because it draws
people into the story you could do the
same thing for your copy and actually
bring people into the scene instead of
telling them what happened in the scene
storytelling tip number two is to juice
up your verbs John Carlton is the king
of power words and in fact when he reads
his copy the first time he goes back a
second time to make tweaks just to the
verbs themselves let me give you some
examples you could start with went home
but a better verb would be he jetted
home or she hit the golf ball versus she
smashed the golf ball or I ate some
pizza versus I gobbled down some pizza
lastly my wife looked at me versus my
wife glared at me right all of those
types of Juiced up verbs make the
sentence significantly more powerful and
visual and they invite a massive
storytelling piece into your copy itself
small tweak but one that will make your
writing explode storytelling tip number
three is be specific instead of saying
he ate some dinner say he ate a steaming
hot plate of homemade lasagna longer but
you see it more visual or I got into my
car and drove to the bank you could say
I got into my 69 red Camaro and drove to
the bank see the difference the visual
there that specificity makes your
writing come alive and your story
storytelling feel more captivating last
example you could say I was out with my
wife last night and she wore a beautiful
dress or you could say I was out with my
wife and she wore this silk Emerald
dress with a gold trim those types of
little nuggets bring your copy to life
make it more Dynamic way more fun to
read and yes I know all the copy boys
are like simple simple simple simple but
it's not going to stick in the person's
brain if they can't visualize it and so
specificity brings out the visualization
which makes your copy sticky
storytelling tip number four is ADD
Stakes Stakes is when there is something
on the line whether for the person in
the story or even the prospect that
could be reading the story let me give
you some examples like in The Hunger
Games Katniss needs to win The Hunger
Games otherwise her district and her
family is going to stay in poverty and
oppression forever the stakes are really
high whether she wins or loses which
keeps you addicted to the story or
Finding Nemo Marlin has to find Nemo
otherwise if he doesn't find Nemo he's
going to lose the only family that he
has left in this world high Stakes or
lastly a story like Harry Potter where
Harry has to take down Voldemort
otherwise evil is going to rule and all
the non-magic folk will perish again
high stakes if this person doesn't
accomplish this what happens or you can
make your prospect be the one that has
to Stakes if you don't invest in this
product this is the thing that could
happen to you not in a fear-mongering
way but in a realistic proposed
storytelling way moving on to
storytelling tip number five is ADD
conflict conflict increases the tension
of your writing and sucks people in to
feel that tension if there's no conflict
and everything is L do dah happy
go-lucky they don't want to read it it's
boring and so when you're telling
stories tell the story that has the most
tension and the most whether it's a
story about yourself and you have
tension and conflict with someone else
or a story about somebody else and they
have tension and conflict with someone
or something else let me give you some
examples like in Toy Story there's this
tension between Buzz and Woody and their
rivalry for Andy's attention and that
tension makes it even more meaningful
when later they become friends but the
tension stays in the entire first couple
of movies because it makes it an
interesting Dynamic of who's going to
get what they really want or in the TV
show Friends Ross and Rachel have this
conflict between will they stay together
won't they stay together and they go
back and forth literally until the very
last episode of France this kept people
engaged in that one Conflict for 10
seasons to see what's going to happen
between that conflict and lastly one of
my favorite examples from Ted lasso is
one of the star characters Jamie tart he
had conflict with himself his own ego
wanting to be the star player and he
believed in himself so much and was only
about himself that he had this conflict
for the first couple Seasons where he
had to wrestle his own emotions and
thoughts which is great because you can
create conflict between the reader and
himself or herself he or she is trying
to make this buying decision that you
are riding copy for and you can expose
the conflict between not buying and
buying what Stakes are at hand what
happens when you do take the next step
forward and investing in your product
great copy creates conflict that the
reader then has to resolve for
themselves whether it is buying your
product or not buying your product the
conflict needs to be resolved
storytelling tip number six is create
Rhythm rhythm in your writing is what's
going to keep people going a slippery
slope down your page as Joe Sugarman
would like to say because usually copy
especially copy that sells can be a lot
longer Gary bangle was famously known
for writing 8 to 13 page sales letters
well how are you going to keep somebody
addicted to your writing for 8 to 13
page sales letters your storytelling has
to have some sort of Rhythm and I can
think of no better example than Gary
Provost example of the five word
sentences here's the example this
sentence has five words five word
sentences are fine but several together
become monotonous listen to what is
happening the writing is getting boring
the sound of it drones it's stuck like a
record the ear demands some variety now
listen I vary the sentence length and I
create music music the writing sings
that has a pleasant Rhythm a lil a
Harmony I use short sentences and I use
sentences of medium length and sometimes
when I'm certain that the reader is
rested I will engage him with a sentence
of considerable length and complexity a
sentence that burns with energy and
builds with all the impetus of a
crescendo the rolls of a drum the
crashing of the symbol sounds that they
listen to this it is important that is a
perfect example example of how to create
rhythm in your writing you can't just
use the same five-word sentences over
and over you need to use sentences to
have one word to three words to 10 words
to short paragraphs to a couple
sentences to one word to a headline you
can vary that formatting to keep people
on their toes as you go down the writing
and the last storytelling tip tip number
seven my personal favorite is to create
open Loops open Loops are the start of a
story that you do not resolve
immediately that's what it means by
opening you're opening up a storyline
that then the reader has to follow
throughout your copy to see how it ends
let me give you some examples here's one
that I've personally used before I tell
you how to double your income let me
share a quick story with you that's an
open loop an open loop says I'm going to
tell you a story about how to double
your income but first let me share a
quick story now I've pivoted right I've
started with this one thing that they're
going to going to hang on because if
they really care on how to double their
income they're going to keep reading
until I finally reveal that to them
that's an open loop here's an open loop
that I read from another copywriter in a
different field that they started with
my client fired me my wife left me and
I'm sleeping under the desk in my office
those are three massive open Loops in a
way to start a story and so now you've
got your reader hooked thinking why did
the client fire him why did his wife
leave him and how long is he going to be
sleeping under this desk for like give
me the story give me the context and
then you can create those open loops and
begin actually resolving them for your
reader A good rule of thumb here is
don't have more than two open Loops at a
time it's too much for your reader to
juggle especially in a short sales
letter or an email and if you're doing
an email I would say one open loop at
best that's it for today's video those
seven storytelling tips will teach you
how to really Master The Art of
Storytelling and copyright writing
itself you get those down and I
guarantee your readers will be addicted
and you'll be able to sell more with
your copy and if you'd like to read a
couple more examples of great
storytelling I've linked three of my
favorite ads down below including Wall
Street Journal a John Cable's ad and a
Claude Hopkins ad that you can go and
read for yourself to enjoy great
storytelling and copyrighting lastly
before you go if you found any value
from today's video I ask you to please
like the video and subscribe to thean
Channel it tells me that you want me to
continue making great videos like this
just for you which I do drop a weekly
video every Saturday for you to enjoy if
you are a copywriter that wraps us up
for today again do not forget your free
gift copyrighting Catalyst in the link
in the description below I hope this
video has served you well and I will
catch you on the next one have you not
subscribed to the channel yet still not
subscribed you see Smash It smash the
Subscribe okay I want you to I want you
to move your mouse that or your finger
could be your finger I want you to go
over
there smash the
Subscribe yeah did you do
it
fantastic really appreciate it more
videos to come for you